who names the show how i met your mother
there's not even any rhyming to it it's
just like a bunch of basic words put
together as a sentence it's not a title
but i digress
harold and kumar
get back on the road this is my car and
we are not picking up a hitchhiker man
hey guys
thanks for picking me up
oh oh
oh
excuse me are you neil patrick harris
yep
oh my god what are you doing holy [ __ ]
dude doogie howser md was like my
favorite show growing up you were my
idol yeah that's great can we get going
i'm bored of [ __ ] back here
go go freaking boring spot
harold and kumar was
very strange i was living in los angeles
and i got a phone call from a friend
that said i'm auditioning for this movie
that you're in and i had no idea what he
was talking about i didn't was not in
any movie
and he said yeah this uh harold and
kumar
get the munchies or something it was
called at the time i think that made no
sense what a weird title that was so i
said are you being serious are you
joking he said you're not aware that
you're you've been written into a movie
like a crazy version of you neil you
wouldn't happen to know how to get on
the highway from here would you dude i
don't even know where the [ __ ] i am
right now
i was at this party earlier tonight and
some guy hooked me up with this
incredible x and next thing i know i'm
being thrown out of a moving car i've
been tripping balls ever since and so
then i kind of panicked
because i don't want to be the
ass of a joke like who's going to play
me that would be weird one of the kids
from home improvement probably so i
called my agent what is this
i'm demand to know they can't
use me in a movie so they sent me the
script
and it was really funny i was flattered
to be honest my only demand was that i
would sign up and then they wouldn't
then rewrite it and change it because as
much as i resp like want to take the
piss out of myself i still want to
respect
the work that i have done and not make
it seem
that i'm tossing middle fingers at my
past
and so they were cool with that and i
got to play this really yeah
messed up version of myself
and they let me improvise a bunch so i
was
licking things and dry humping things
just a normal day at work two words
starship
[ __ ] troopers
if you want to know the secret of being
you will come with us
uh please i i really need to go
of course i'm so sorry to bother you you
move along
i had to film i think on an actual
unicorn which is a challenge contrary to
popular belief they don't really exist
but i believe there was some sort of
horse that had something super glued on
its forehead and i remember being in a
weird green screen studio kind of like
this but everything was green and i'm
trying to be like i was tripping on
mushrooms and that was one of those
what's what what has happened to my life
like where
how did i go from small town new mexico
singing in the episcopal church choir
to tripping balls
on an actual four-legged animal in a
green screen room and i've had more than
a few of those
thoughts in my life as i'm sure you will
soon find out bye
i love you
i wasn't really looking to change
anyone's
perception of me because i had just done
mark in rent which was pretty hipster
cool east village so i was just excited
to be doing new gigs my favorite thing
about working is just the new chapters i
get a little bit tired of redundancy and
maybe just because i've been doing it
for so long so the harold and kumar
thing seemed super fun again a couple
just a couple days work john and cal who
played harold and kumar
were exhausted been filming nights and i
just came in and you know stole their
car
found some strippers and then went home
it was another great gig
doogiehousermd
we did a chest x-ray ekg and an
echocardiogram he has a murmur of mitral
insufficiency i gave him to jockson.125
milligrams lasix 20 milligrams vid and
aldacton 12.5 milligrams pid also i'd
like to send them to nuclear medicine
for a cardiac scan at 9 30. thank you dr
house i grew up in a small town in new
mexico and i happened to randomly be
cast in a movie opposite whoopi goldberg
which is not ever something one says but
it happened and then i was still living
in ruidoso and because i'd been in that
movie i had an agent we had never wanted
to do television because it would meant
that the family would have to move to
los angeles and my parents were both
attorneys couldn't practice in
california so
we were only movie people
and so they said we'd only do a tv show
if if it was a stephen bochko type show
because they were huge fans of l.a law
and hill street blues
which were big giant shows
back in the 80s and 90s
and so wouldn't you know stephen bachcha
wrote this show like a half hour show
that starred
smartypants doctor person we said uh
okay
well we should meet and we'll meet him
and i met him and he didn't think i was
right for it to be honest and so they
did this big giant nationwide search to
try and find doogiehouser i think i must
have met him too early like early in the
process before maybe they had really
started casting so i ended up finally
getting the gig and when i arrived on
set the first day the crew members were
wearing t-shirts that said i'll play
doogie because they had what they had
taken so long to cast the role which is
kind of insulting seeing as i auditioned
for really really early in the process
but
i'm not going to complain about it
because i got the gig
and four years later people liked it and
27 years later they still call me doogie
so look at that
full circle it's not just the heat it's
everything someone i'm trying to save
almost kills me i've worked 40 out of
the last 48 hours juan is not speaking
to me because i never showed up at the
stones concert and i have to do a dance
to get anyone to listen to me here
dookiehauser was pretty much my same age
and we were both experiencing really
weird professional lives outside of what
adolescent life would be he in a
hospital me in a hospital set i felt
great kinship to him it was kind of
interesting i think they hoped that i
would have had that
physical inability to ever grow i think
they hoped i'd have been one of those
kid actors that just always looked like
they were nine because when i first got
the gig i was i was like pre-puberty
even though i was almost 16 years old
and then my testicles dropped and
suddenly i was like a foot and a half
taller so they didn't love that because
i think they wanted me to be this cute
kid the whole time and so they had to re
like adjust to my adam's apple and my
acne lighting does amazing things doogie
houser ran for four seasons which isn't
a ton but it was on tv at a time when
syndication then started happening when
you ran four seasons so i think more
people feel that it ran for a decade
and in point of fact it was kind of
unceremoniously cancelled i was actually
in vancouver filming a television movie
and i read in uh a newspaper that the
show had been canceled i didn't feel
disrespected by it all of this is one
big business so
i got the gig i got four years of
amazing
experiences i guess a phone call would
have been nice but they you know they
have a call list
i forget to call friends
how i met your mother
hey loser how's not playing laser tag
because playing laser tag is awesome
i killed you connor don't make me get
your mom hey listen i need your opinion
on something okay meet me at the bar in
15 minutes and suit up after a healthy
amount of time not working on tv i
thought one year that it would be a good
idea to try and get some steady work as
the next chapter and then i got an
audition for this show called how i met
your mother which i thought was a
terrible title when you have
friends and
three's company
you know something that looks good on a
cap and then i read the part and it was
to play someone who was like
rotund
cigar smoking jack black murph
and i thought i i don't even i don't
even know what am i this is a
multi-camera
comedy show where i'm not gonna get this
job but i knew the casting director and
she said yeah go and they like you
they've seen harold and kumar oh that's
cool all right and i was in the hallway
with these other actors i thought this
is ridiculous this is an la actor's
story right now because i'm just gonna
go in and not get the job and i sat in
traffic all day for another audition i'm
not gonna get and so i didn't really
care i didn't think i was gonna get it
so i went in
i said hey to them and i was the laser
tag scene so i was just like i think i
did a dive role and like knocked into
their desk and i think that worked they
liked it and they thought as good
writers do they thought well it doesn't
have to be this it could actually maybe
be this and i thought it would just be
at the pilot and would never go because
of the title who names the show how i
met your mother
there's not even any rhyming to it like
a bunch of basic words put together as a
sentence it's not a title but i digress
and then it like kept on trucking and
barney was this like crazy fun
delusional monkey head that got to
every episode
try different rules and pretend that
life was
way more exciting than it actually was
and lie about dates and claim that he
accomplished things that he hadn't wear
sharp suits all the time so to be the
devil on your shoulder great gig did it
for nine years loved it i request the
highest of fives i have a lot of respect
for
carter baze and craig thomas who created
and wrote the show because while they
wanted it to be ridiculous and it was a
laugh track show with lots of little you
know with four cameras filming it they
really liked the heart of ted and the
pathos of reality so a barney was an
extreme
part of an ensemble where ted was sort
of the serious truth part of the
ensemble they knew over time that they
wanted the story to evolve the way
humans evolve because once it started to
catch on and we were doing season six
seven eight then then i think they
realized like you're not just going to
do this same funny show over and over
because we're we're heading towards a
conclusion
that they knew very very early on
apparently that everyone needed to grow
and change i think bonnie's evolution
mostly came about from
my falling in love with kobe smulders
barney just say it
i think i'm in love with robin we knew
that robin wasn't the one in the pilot
episode he says that's why i met your
aunt aunt robin so i was
a second she's so talented and hot and
funny and canadian already that's four
stars she's just amazing so i started
flirting with her as much as i could on
camera and that barney could do all of
that i just was kind of like had a
talent crush on kobe they sort of saw
our chemistry change and then that
shifted barney into being more
single-minded
and really
honoring the notion of
changing who he is and changing his ways
as much as he was able now the golden
rule is love thy neighbor but there's
one rule above it the platinum rule
never ever ever ever
love thy neighbor i meet a lot of
straight
frat
kind of guys at bars that are super
stoked that i the guy who played bonnie
stinson and some of them tell me that
they're not gay but that they would fool
around with me that doesn't happen
nearly enough
the follow-through do you understand but
i'm flattered by by the idea of it by
the notion of it
hedwig and the angry inch
hedwig and the angry was just nuts
because that's live theater and i hold
the live theater event in really high
regard meaning that when i see theater
i'm boring into the actors you know i'm
really judging them to see if they're
phoning it in
and sometimes it's like it feels like
it's the first time they've ever done
this and it's spectacular and i think
that's not true they do this eight times
a week but here they are like doing the
singular thing so i hold them in real
high regard hedwig is essentially a one
woman show where you're singing
everything very david bowie punk rock
style
i had to be as effeminate as one could
be
without making light of it
i'd never even done drag ever or worn
heels really ever so i had to not only
learn all of that so super quickly but i
also had to commit to it in such a
degree that the audience who was boring
into me didn't think that i was faking
it because i was faking it because i
hadn't done it so it was a lot of work
but it was so different from myself that
i was sort of able to
take on
the newness of it all like shaving my
body losing 20 pounds it was a crazy
chapter in my life i looked very
emaciated i had to carry myself more
like tits out
swivel hip then shoulders strong square
frame and that's a weird place to exist
when i haven't done that so all of it
was crazy and super fun but the fun
thing about hedwig if i'm being honest
and i hope i get another crack at it
someday the more wisdom she has the more
she knows the better it is but more so
the worse she is the better it is
that's a hard one for me because i want
to be good i want to be on a stage where
people go ah good choice actor
oh i love the vibrato at the end nice
musical note harris if hedwig's too good
then she'd be famous like every time my
voice was bad it was better every time i
messed up on the choreography it was it
made more sense
which was a mind [ __ ] if you're too
polished in what you do karma will come
and remind you in some swift way that
you know you're mortal
[Music]
starship troopers
every day federal scientists are looking
for new ways to kill bugs
your basic arachnid warrior isn't too
smart but you can blow off a limb
and it's still 86 combat effective
here's a tip aim for the nerve stem and
put it down for good
would you like to know more back in the
mid 90s when you were an actor on
television you weren't welcomed into the
uh world of film and in turn if you were
a film actor you weren't really welcomed
into the world of television they were
very separate beasts so having done a tv
show at a very
relatively young age i kept trying to be
in movies but i was just a tv person
which is fine you know you hope that you
can pull a sally field
and just like
stick around long enough that the rules
change but i auditioned now and again
and i did get a a movie in a part in a
paul verhoeven movie called starship
troopers which was super cool because it
was one of the first cg movies with
giant cg bugs we're in this for the
species boys and girls it's simple
numbers they have more and every day i
have to make decisions that send
hundreds of people like you to their
deaths that's what the mobile infantry's
good for
i hope you're ready for more
we're going back to pee
to capture that brain
it was fun i was sort of the brainy
person i had second sight i could know
what people were thinking instead of
being one of the soldiers and got to
shoot guns and do the cool scenes i was
just whisked away and then came back
wearing
like a remarkably militaristic black
leather trench coat and stomped around
and sort of said everything's fine carry
on which was fun in one way because i
didn't have to be on set all of the time
wearing this like
uniforms and helmets and you know trying
to avoid jake busey's errant
shot pattern but in turn everyone else
got to go with captain dale dye
on training missions and bonds together
as this group and i just show up after
they were all exhausted for two weeks of
filming in wyoming and i'd touch a bug
and say it's afraid
it's afraid it's afraid
that would be my day and i'd leave
so i love it still holds up that movie
quite well surprisingly if you watch cgi
and a lot of movies that were filmed
after that
it still it looks very much like a fake
entity but
phil tippett was the name of the man who
did
all of those bugs and he did a really
bang-up job because those
that movie still holds up really well
gone girl
amy i am so
happy that you are here
and i don't want you to worry for one
moment there are cameras everywhere
the exterior all along the grounds the
entryway anyone who is caught coming or
going
will be recorded
you are more than safe
and i am not letting you get away again
i'm a huge david fincher fan
the game which is a michael douglas
movie that sean penn was in is one of my
favorite movies of all time i'm obsessed
a bit with escape rooms and with
immersive theater and the notion that
content doesn't need to be on a screen
or even on stage so this movie kind of
delves deeply into that as an idea i got
an opportunity to
meet david fincher to see about maybe
being in a movie that's all i knew and
it wasn't an audition it was just go
have lunch with the guy which was
terrifying it's worse than auditioning
because you at least in audition you
have like you come prepared with a thing
but i'm thinking
what am i suppose if i do i talk too
much do i like do research and then show
him how much i know about him that feels
stalkery do i wait and let him sort of
come to me and tell me about the role
and i'll act actor aloof i'm like yeah
maybe i'll take a look at the script no
that seems like a stupid idea and we
just started talking and we just talked
for the whole time about nonsense good
great stuff about crossword puzzles and
scripts and we had a lot of similarities
i think a lot of people are scared of
david fincher because he's exacting
he does 40 50 takes but i somehow made
him laugh a bit and i'm just enamored by
him i've never felt with a director as
much as him that i was in the hands of a
sculptor it just felt like he would take
a shot and spend so much time lighting
it and then he would take an equal
amount of time with the actors and it we
just chisel away so all of the things
that i would do he'd say stop doing
those things with your eyes just do it
again not because i did a thing with my
eye but because of 17 things and then by
the time take 30 34 37 came around you
you're simplified it sort of distilled
all of the weird tweaky isms that
you practice in the bathroom mirror and
then you get there and you rally really
do it so it felt very truthful
so
it was fun to play super subtle in that
world i was also playing someone who you
weren't sure about their intentions
playing something very simple when you
don't know whether they're being
truthful or deceitful is is fun and then
i got my throat slit mid orgasm also fun
who knew
[Music]
uncoupled
uncoupled i played michael who's in a
long term 17-year relationship
monogamous relationship with his
boyfriend colin and on colin's 50th
birthday michael's throwing him a party
a big surprise party and as he's about
to open the door colin says that he's
leaving him and then the door opens and
everyone goes surprised and they have to
deal with this party where everyone has
no idea that that just happened michael
and the is just been punched in the
stomach with news that he doesn't
understand and the whole show is kind of
a breakup show
of like having to figure out
what happened but also then now what
happens what happened what happens
now i'm 47 i've only been with one dude
since before
dating apps
and now i'm in new york city a real
estate agent handsome af but old you
know what i'm saying and
have to date people on grindr i don't
know
what that means hey
let me pick a photo
um
oh how about this one we just had it
taken it's our company ad that crop out
suzanne sorry darling you're a bit
ragged around the eyes suzanne looks
great though she should crop you out and
put it on her profile
this is why you have no friends so
that's the show it was transformational
in a very weird way because i'm in an
18-year relationship with someone who
thankfully has not broken up with me but
like my online dating was aol chat rooms
you'd be in a little thing with 14 other
names and then you'd awkwardly type sup
and then that would appear and then you
just sort of wait
for like a a direct message
that would say you know pick
and i'd go to all the hot guy picks i
had i
i'd send him that one
you they'd send me some other pick i
assumed that wasn't them i was probably
talking to a 95 year old woman in
kansas but her pick was like of a stud
and then we'd like chat that was dating
for me long time ago so i don't know any
of this stuff so it was fun to play
someone who also didn't know and i kind
of got to live vicariously through my
character michael i mean i
just feel like i should mark this moment
with something
new something i haven't done before
isn't this something you haven't done
before
i guess it is
and i'm in a great state of undress
through a lot of it because you're
seeing me having sex with strange
handsome people that we don't really
connect but yeah it's fun it's it's
weirdly touching i think what darren
starr does really well and has done it
through sex in the city and younger
and emily in paris in its own way
is intense situations
that are comedic and heartfelt that kind
of everyone can rally around
so even though this is a singular story
that i just told it's a breakup story
that is ridiculous at many times and
also like like very heartfelt like
there's some really sad like tender
moments which happens in breakup and i
think to define breakup in both of those
tones was a smart call because in life
when you're broken up with
you cry about the weirdest things but
you also act ridiculous in certain ways
[Music]
it's not like just a sad show but it's
also not just a stupid funny
shticky show it's everything and
my butt
so i mean if that's not gonna sell it i
don't know what is sad
pratfalls
taint
you're gonna see all three the trifecta
we act to play parts it's all
transformation whether it's gran goon
y'all or whether it's really like nuance
it's all
transformational i look for gigs as like
new bucket list-y things that i haven't
done before that said i'm getting a
little tired
i haven't hosted the tony awards since i
did that at radio city music hall
because i thought that was so fun and it
was like so good i don't want to try and
top it but i you can't really top it not
that it's unachievable but it's like
that shouldn't be your goal i don't want
to keep just trying to
reinvent my own wheel i think my my
future will steer more towards
directing because as fun as it is to be
an exciting paint color on a palette
when lana wachowski is the painter
and she's in charge of your color it's
exquisite and it's so fun to be a part
of it but i'm anxious to start painting
i think